to us about tractability in a simple
over parameterized model
okay thanks to to the organizer so what
i'll talk about is a paper that
we are finishing writing and hopefully
we'll be on archive next week or
something like that with with each other
and
congratulations
and okay let me start with an appetizer
that is an interesting geometric
question
and it's the following
uh so even if i are not interested in
statistics this is an interesting math
question
you have iad gaussian vectors in rd and
of them and out of them you construct a
polytope a random polytop
so this is defined as the set of vector
theta
in rd
such that x i
theta is less or equal than one
ferrolites
okay so
so the picture is that you have rd of
course
and then you cut it with planes
half spaces
and then you look at the intersection of
all of these each of this half space
contains the origin
so this is non-empty
and so this is my set and the natural
question is what is the radius
of this set
okay so the radius is of course the
maximum norm of any the maximum l2 norm
of any vector
in this set
and okay a corollary
of of the theorem that i'll state a
little bit later in this in this talk is
the following
uh with positive probability so let's
take an
indeed going to infinity with n over d
going to some
number delta
and one thing that we can prove is that
with
with positive
probability
and i can i can describe in a minute
what this means precisely
uh if you want
the radius of this set
is what well of course more and more
hyperplane means smaller and smaller
radius the set is
you know monotonically decreasing
and it turns out that is decreasing
quite slowly is one over square root of
two log
delta
plus smaller in delta
of one over
octet
okay
and and precisely
you know to be more precise this means
that the limit
of the probability
that the radius
of end
is bigger or equal than
1 over square root 2
log delta plus
epsilon
over
log delta
there is an epsilon of delta going to
zero such that this limit
and going to infinity this limit is
equal to zero
and the limit with the minus
and less or equal
is less or equal than a constant less
than one okay so on one side is a high
probability bound and the other side
is a positive probability bound
unfortunately we don't have the tight
threshold
the best uh known result about this this
geometric
prop problem before before
you know our work become was there is a
paper by
baldi machining
actually of this year
that proves
that the probability
that the radius
of the same set
is
bigger than
one plus epsilon over square root of two
log
delta
is less or equal than e to the minus d
so it's it's only uh one side of this
two bound and is a you know the epsilon
is in front of the one over square root
two log
instead of of of the thing
okay so this is uh the the geometric
question
uh let me tell you
why i was interested in this problem
actually i discovered the connection
with this more or less
at the end yeah did they prove that for
a fixed positive epsilon or is there
some yeah
this is uh this is uh
okay so the the
okay the precise statement is the
following that for any epsilon
for any epsilon there exists c of
epsilon such that if i think n over d
is bigger than c of epsilon then this
happens
okay and the nice thing is that in is
non-asymptotic
they have an explicit error bound now
the way stated is is slightly different
okay if you like geometry there is a
dual of this problem that is the
following
take n random points there is another
way of constructing a random polygon
right you you throw endpoint and then
you you look at
at the convex envelope of this point and
then you look at the inner radius of
this convex envelope right
the inner radius inner radius means the
radius of the largest ball that is in
contained inside
the relation is that one is the inverse
of the other
and so they state the result for this
one
okay so let me say you know now that i
stated one theorem a word of motivation
why i am interested in this motivator
does this because of
machine learning of
statistics so say that you have a
supervised learning data
problem
with
a parametric family
and the excise are in rd
and traps you have a loss l
that is
r times r
to are
equal to then zero and uh
and okay there is there is uh
uh
you know
a lot of interesting there has been a
lot of interest over the last couple of
years in interpolators
so what are interpolators these are
models that
uh
interpolate the data that is achieved
zero zero loss so
okay so here say that the vector of
parameters is a p dimensional vectors
and we are interested in okay what i
call
erm0
so this is the setup vector of
parameters such that l of y i
f of
x i
and theta
is equal to 0
for all i
less than
okay
um
okay so so of course you know okay the
loss of course we we all know examples
uh
think of this or classification laws
okay
so if you start thinking of this this
problem there are a couple of questions
that you of you know
of uh
start
okay so so the the why there is interest
in this because many modern machine
learning systems
work by finding an interpolator so not
only minimizing the empirical risk by
finding you know a model that that
achieve nearly zero empirical risk so
there are two theory questions
one is
when is erm0
not empty
or 3 question
question 2 when can we find it in
polytime
and question three is
uh
what is what are the generalization
properties
what are the generalization properties
in particular the vector theta that is
found in polytime
and
okay these three questions have been
have been studied in some detail
uh for very simple losses so
studied
for
linear models
namely
when f
x theta
is basically theta times x
and square loss
okay uh
so this includes a special case kernel
methods random feature methods linear
regression
and you know i wrote some papers about
this peter wrote some papers sachara
clean others
now
uh
yeah so it would be interesting to move
beyond uh
so in this case in this case of linear
model this in particular these first two
questions are very easy because the set
of interpolators each each of these
constraints is a linear constraint so
constraint theta to stay on a fine space
and finding polytime is very easy by by
grading descent by convexity
okay so i want to study a little bit the
simplest example
non-convex example
that has a little bit of structure and
the simplest non-combat
convex example turns out or i believe is
binary classification
linear binary classification
with the negative margin
so the the bad aspect about this this
specific aspect is that there is some
nice math the bad aspect is that is not
a method that i would recommend to
anybody for any practical classification
problem
but you know perhaps the hope is that we
gain some insight by studying this
example and then we can apply
to other cases so this is also known in
starting with the physics literature as
the negative perceptor
so what is this case this case is simply
the case in which my function is linear
and my loss
is
zero
if y hat y
is bigger or equal than kappa
and some positive quantity
if y hat y
is less than kappa and here the the
caveat is that so this is
classification with a margin cap
the important feature here is that the
data
will not be linearly separable not
linearly
separable
so we cannot do usual max margin
classification and i'll take kappa
negative
so in this case what is the set of
empirical risk minimizer
or the set of solutions
is the set of vector theta
and so i have to normalize them in the
unit sphere in d dimension
such that y i
x i theta
is bigger or equal than kappa for all i
okay
let me now define something about the
model under which i want to study this
so i will study this under okay i will
take as as a step before andy going to
infinity
and over d2 delta
and
i study two models
pure noise model
this means that the features will be
normal zero id
and the labels are just random
uniform if you want plus minus one
independent of
of the x i and
what we call linear signal model
and
this x i
normal 0d
and
probability of y i
equal plus 1 given x i
is fee of x i
times theta star for some vector theta
star
and okay so the assumption on the
function fee is that
phi is exponential t so phi of t is
goes like 1 plus 1 minus
e to the minus alpha t plus
smaller order terms as t goes to
infinity
and e to the alpha ts t goes to
plus smaller order term as t goes to
minus infinity
and okay and the two things that i'm
interested in is of course
okay what i call that s kappa this is
the you know the satisfiability or the
existence threshold
this is the soup
of all delta
such that lim
and d
to infinity n over d to delta
p
of erm
0 not empty
is strictly positive
perhaps limit
and delta alg
kappa is you know basically the same
but with the
super delta
such that there exists a polytime
algorithm
so these are the two things ideally i
would like to to compute and
okay so let me now
uh briefly review what what what is
previous work on this on this problem
and then state my result
so meanwhile perhaps you can
think if you have
any question about the statement of the
problem
well i erased this
okay any questions about the
problem statement
so if i if i have to trace a figure so
let's do a figure right perhaps this
stimulates some question
what you have is that you have a
the sphere as d minus one
and each one of these constraints here
uh
you know or each one of these
constraints here
cut a spherical cap from this
sphere
okay so i have a vector and then i cut
out a spherical cap
i cut out another spherical cup
cut out another spherical cup and then
i'm
i'm left with this kind of
you know swiss cheese shape
and i want to know whether the swiss
shape
which is shape is empty or not
this is equivalent to the polytop figure
that i draw before
now the equivalent picture is that you
have a polytop
and i'm intersecting it to the unit ball
and then i'm interested in this region
this region this region everything that
stays inside the point
yeah so so so the results that i mean we
have some results about three but
they're not so i'll
i'll give the results about one and two
that we have
i state some results about one and two
in the paper we have some results about
three but
yeah
so so here
y i x i
is this
and so i'm cutting off anything that is
less than
kappa
kappa is negative
that are not separable
okay so what is known of course the case
capital positive has been studied for a
while
since cover 96
1965
top equals zero so what you prove this
delta s at kappa equals zero in my
language is equal to two
elisabeth gardner
using physics method 1988 using replica
methods
computer delta s
kappa
for kappa positive
uh this was proved by srivina
tirotsi
2003
and by sturgeonish
so starting is a simpler proof based on
on on
gaussian comparison and then there is uh
more recent papers for instance the
manual candice and pragueis were
considered so this is all with the
random labels
so it's the pure noise
case and then there is results with
linear signal
in my terminology by by
candace
sur
and myself and fender one
so
myself
in this case of course all of this is
about delta s
delta s and in this case the problem is
come back so that is equal to that
algorithmic
all right the case of kappa negative
has received much less interest so one
not notice here is that this proof
implies that okay let me write it here
the proof of storage niche also implies
that a bound for kappa negative
starting
2013
implies that delta s of kappa
is always upper bounded by what's called
the replica symmetric formula
that is 1 over the expectation
of
kappa plus g positive part square
where g as a standard normal random
variable
okay for kappa negative
this is much less studied uh
has been studied quite a bit in physics
since a work by france
and parisi
2016
that studied it as a simple model for
jamming so this is using replicas
and
i don't know of any other mathematical
results apart from this target and the
paper by a recent paper by ahmed
that that 2000 perhaps 20
that give an algorithm under under the
assumption that there is no overload gap
okay
yeah so so so the also question good
question what does this paper do this
paper writes the
uh
full replica method breaking formula and
and yeah so so they they claim that
you you need full replica symmetry break
to achieve the theme right so and they
compute then their main interest is
really computing certain exponents of
how this solution behaves as you move to
the
phase transition boundary
okay so perhaps so
uh because you want it uh you want it on
the sphere right
right in the case in which kappa is
positive
you can always move from the sphere to
the full ball
okay so the problem is equivalent to a
convex problem in the case of kappa is
negative you cannot you know if you have
a solution or smaller norm this doesn't
satisfy the original problem
all right all right um
okay so let me perhaps for comparison
the replica symmetric formula
let me uh write for you how does this
behave uh this is uh
if you do this integral this is
this is what is one
is fi cap over kappa kappa square over
fi cap
times one plus small of kappa of one
yeah if you do this integral where this
is the gaussian cdf
so feet up is the gaussian cdf
and and
perhaps is obvious but the way the
reason why this pickup
appears is that
erase this
if i fix a vector theta
for a given vector theta the probability
that
uh
in the purely random model say the
probability that this is less than
kappa so the probability that
the constraint is violated
is exactly fit up
right so what is the naive calculation
the calculation is you know if you give
me a vector theta what is the
probability that it satisfy all the
constraints
is one minus
phi kappa
to the x
each constraint is satisfied with
private one minus capital to the n
okay
how many vectors there are on the sphere
about e to the d
so you would expect that the right scale
is e to the
minus c d when this happens then there
is the phase transition
so if you write it down this means that
sofitappa must be quite small
so it will minus and pick up
perhaps about e to the minus c times d
so you would expect that interesting
stuff interesting regime
is
delta of order
one over theta lastly
all right so this explains this this
this behavior one of you fikappa that
you see in the replica symmetric bound
and and you'll see in all the results
that i state
actually now i state one theorem that
collects all the things that i want to
talk about
okay so i'll collect all the results
that we have about questions one
and two so for pure noise
model
what we prove is that delta s
of kappa
is
uh log
kappa
over phi kappa
times one plus molar in kappa one
and
delta arg
of kappa
is bigger or equal than one over thick
up
one plus molar cup of one
so i'm taking you know always in the
definition of this i already taken n and
d going to infinity and then
uh yeah we have formulas bounds for each
kappa but this bounds becomes
you know
tight for kappa large
and for the linear signal
a very similar picture
delta s
of kappa
is
e to the alpha times
kappa times
log
kappa divided by 4
v kappa
times 1 plus molar
of one
here in small load the subscript is the
asymptotic variable
and delta
of kappa
is
e to the alpha kappa
and then there is two
fitapa
oneplus moloka
so
okay
uh so so so what this tells us is that
okay first of all the replica symmetric
bound is is loose is is wrong by factor
kappa square
and second that you can pinpoint at
least for large couple you know the
thing to the leading order
and third that there is a large gap
between
what we can achieve algorithmically and
and you know the threshold the existence
threshold of solutions
okay so
the picture is like this
yeah alpha times kappa yeah alpha times
kappa yeah so so these thresholds move
up of course when there is a linear
signal because
okay the data
the data
are so you want to separate the data so
the linear signal the data look more or
less like this so it's easier to
separate them instead if they're purely
random it's harder to separate
okay so this is
the picture right
kappa delta
and then this is replica symmetric and
the symmetric goes up formula and now we
know that the right threshold is
somewhere
down here
this is delta
rs
and then
that there exists an algorithmic
threshold
that is even lower
i mean we don't know if it's lower but
we have a lower bound that is so lower
than that
yeah
okay so good question excellent question
because this is the the next thing that
i want to describe what is the algorithm
and i'm sorry for all all the people
that are smart at you know coming up
with smart algorithms in this room this
is
this is very stupid what i'm gonna say
so let me take the pure noise case or
for simplicity all the y i
plus 1 is completely identical
and what is the idea we want to solve
want to solve
uh what i want to solve i want to sort
maximize ideally
data
subject to
excite theta
let's say bigger or equal than
kappa
for all i okay so this is what i would
like to
to do if i find one solution that is
norm bigger than one i want okay this is
equivalent to our problem right
uh
okay so we have this poly top
and we want to get something as far as
possible from the origin
and we do something really stupid we
take a random vector and we maximize the
linear function
okay and if you want the justification
okay the justification you can think of
it like this if you call this your
objective function
you can think of linearizing the
objective function around the random
initialization
and maximize this okay
where theta zero equal v is let's say
normal zero
or epsilon b
and v
is normal zero identity all right so you
can think of this as starting at the
random initialization and doing just one
step of frankfurt algorithm
if you are an optimization person
okay um so so again so what we do is
maximize
b
times theta
subject to
theta x i
less or equal than kappa for a life okay
and now this is a convex program and and
it's it's quite easy to
it's relatively easy to to analyze
precisely once
you get so this is a linear program once
you get the linear programming solution
you come up and construct an estimator
just by normalizing
that satisfies copper margin solution by
normalizing
if if the norm is at least one this is a
energy solution and the analysis says
that if
if
if delta is below this threshold or this
threshold depending on the model
then the norm will be bigger than one
with our probability
this is the algorithm
okay so
i think that's
more or less all that i wanted to say
perhaps let me
say a couple of things about open
questions here
okay say
open questions
okay not naturally for this type of
workshop is it would be interesting to
figure out whether
there is really a gap between delta
out and then star
delta s and the taub
[Music]
this is actually something that i think
can be done with with existing
techniques so let me see in progress
uh
uh there is there is another question is
you know if you if you look at the
physics papers and you try to interpret
them the picture that i have in mind is
that
there is here a kind of
point in which these three are no not
like this but
the replica symmetric is always wrong
but at a certain point these two
threshold coincides there is some regime
in which
you know the two thresholds coincide the
algorithm and the statistics and then
and then perhaps the perhaps possibly
they differ
so it would be interesting to understand
this
yeah okay let's say sharp
okay two
sharp threshold
we don't prove that he's at zero one
and then
in the sense of a sharp threshold in
their sense there exists in the sense of
concentration
and three
you know full replica symmetry breaking
formula
let's see four you know existence of a
region
region
of kappa
yeah with
delta
equal delta s
okay
so this is
this is perhaps in order of difficulty
nearly
what kind of evidence that is for one
not by very little but i think
i think you know it
should be possible to do the overlapped
cup calculation and i suspect that it
gives
it gives what it should be but okay we
we didn't yet we don't have any results
that i can put on this yet
okay that's all i guess thank you
uh questions
just to make sure if you believe silvio
france and france paris and georgia
parisi
the the transition is directly from
replica symmetry to full or there is a
one rsb phase or what what is this
region where they are the same does that
uh
okay so there is a that is something
like this
okay let me
remember here
there is here a phase in which
so there is a you know there is a
replica if you if you look at you know
the volume
so there is a phase where it's replica
symmetric and then when you move up
there is a phase in which there is
uh
rsb and then uh
okay so it's unclear what happens here
whether and then there is this you know
satisfiability phase transition up there
and now it's unclear whether i mean i
don't remember exactly but here there
must be an intermediate phase in which
is one rsb
and then there is what's called a
gardner transition here
okay so there is something yeah so this
is the picture
so so this is at
this is at large kappa
you know sufficiently small kappa some
of these this transition coincide right
so i don't remember whether these two
are but
but yeah okay so
it's a it's a you know quite typical
kind of phase diagram that you see in
constraint satisfaction problems the the
the difference here is that it is uh
with continuous variables you know that
make you know some of you know the trick
that are available with discrete
variable
questions
yeah back to the algorithm so for for
many of these
spin glassy problems one needs you know
fancy message passing algorithms but
here can user a feel good explanation
for why something simple worked here
like pick a random direction and and go
in it
uh
okay so so what is my intuition why this
might this stupid thing might be
perhaps not so bad is
you know what happens in this picture is
that
if you if you carve this little you know
for kappa large negative you are carving
very little
balls out of this big ball right so if
you think now you know the energy
landscape this means that this i expect
it to be correlated on
only very small scales right
so you know for very small kappa will be
very uncorrelated and so will be you
know
very difficult to make uh
progress
you know starting on a position and
doing something smart
now that said you know what one thing
that we did and
is that we we
we and i mean
uh you know
mark and ahmed brought the you know
kind of optimal approximate message
passing for it
for this problem this is supposedly give
the good yeah we believe perhaps it
gives the the right algorithmic
threshold
uh
it's not clear how to you know at least
meet how to analyze
you know you get a formula for for what
is the result that is similar to parisi
formula it's it's quite it's not easy to
compute the asymptotics of that formula
for large kappa and see where it falls
down in this diagram and compare it but
this is one thing that is
yeah yeah it might do better yeah i
don't know i don't know if it does
better asymptotically right i don't i
don't know right i can write a formula
and you know wrote the formula
you know
have a you know it's a formula it's
written easily in terms of a
minimization problem over measures or in
terms of a stochastic optimal control
problem
and then taking the asymptotics for
large cup of this formula is
let's say future work
so for that message
for that message
so uh for the message passing algorithm
these caps i assume are the constraint
nodes what are the variable nodes
now the variables are the theta is the
vector theta right and then i see okay
and
so the message passing algorithm takes
basically the
take this matrix x with the rows x1 to
say that you're in the pure noise
and then proceed by you know right and
left multiplication
by x and then you know
you write an optimal control problems
for the functions and this you know as a
dual that is a paris like formula
and uh okay so
so it's kind of implicit so at least
analytically it's difficult to to say
at least to me at the moment it's
difficult to say
a lot about it
so it's a it's a dense factory graph but
where in some sense the couplings are
weak if the things being if the if kappa
is very negative you're right okay it
should yeah you expect that
yeah at any given point there is only a
small number of them
but otherwise this is very similar to
you know
formally two problems that we know how
to deal with
words about the proof technique is it
based on gaussian comparison
uh
yeah so this part is
you know the analysis of this algorithm
is gaussian comparison uh
with a statistical threshold the output
the upper bound
uh the upper bound the r is about some
comparison but not in a plane way
because in the plane way it gives you if
you use gordon inequality it gives you
the replica asymmetric formula
so there is a trick there that we we do
basically
we apply garden gardening quality but
not to the obvious quantity that is so
we have to construct a certain quantity
and it's somehow actually it's very nice
and you know this was a surprise to me
that if you apply to the right thing it
gives you this formula that at least
leading order is you know tight and it's
a replica symmetry breaking formula
and for the lower bound is kind of
weighted second mode
moment method
yeah so you have to find the right way
thing to
to make second moment better and this is
the reason why
why we have positive probability not
high probability
we didn't think a lot of trying to prove
a sharp threshold so that you know high
probability but that might be within
reach
[Music]
okay
other questions
is there any intuition like this log
factor in this satisfied sorry like
delta s k cover so you have this log
absolute value of copper
is there i don't know
okay there is another way of proving uh
upper bound by
chaining so so here it's a bit
mysterious
right in this proof there is a way to
prove this upper bound that
eventually will not appear in the paper
but you can you know the point is that
you know you cannot use first order
method to get do with the upper bound
because
so one way to do it is you look at the
process that is the number of
unsatisfied constraints and then
you do some chaining for you you lower
bound the minimum of this and you do
some training to lower boundaries and
then the the log kappa shows up as
i don't remember by whether the number
of level you know the lowest level in
the chaining uh thing that you have to
go to or something like that
in that setting so so you have to take
you know as kappa you know grows a kind
of finer and finer
i think you know makes sense right what
i said before if kappa grows if you
think of this landscape this becomes
less and less correlated i mean
the the correlation becomes more and
shorter and shorter range and so because
of that if you think of in terms of
chaining you have to go to a t you know
dancer and dancer grid to make chaining
work right
and if i remember correctly that is what
in that proof make the lock cup up here